[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro d'on va plus loin c'est
la dernière de la saison donc me
bouleversons un petit peu le programme
grand débat consacré aux événements
marquants de l'année choisie par nos
invités eux mêmes mais on ne pouvait pas
évidemment passer à côté de la polémique
du jour révélée par nos confrères du
monde on appelle déjà la sphère benalla
c'est le nom du conseiller sécurité d'
emmanuel macron filmé en train de
frapper un manifestant le 1er mai
dernier pourtant un casque un brassard
de policiers avalanche de réactions et
de condamnation le parquet de paris
ouvre une enquête préliminaire
plus les heures passent plus les zones
d'ombré s'accumulent autour de l'homme
de sa fonction et de son statut dans
l'équipe macron cette affaire peut-elle
viré au scandale d'état nous poserons la
question à nos invités ne manquait pas
de réagir sur twitter avec le hashtag au
vpn notre match des idées il opposera ce
soir arnaud benedetti à jacky isabello
nous reviendrons sur la communication
des manuels macron depuis un an
il ne voulait pas de présidences bavarde
sa parole était rare elle est maintenant
quasi quotidienne sauf aujourd'hui dans
la sphère benalla silence radio et ça ne
passe pas inaperçu y at il encore une
logique dans la communication de
l'elysée quelle est la part
d'improvisation nous en débattrons avec
nos spécialistes
l'entretien du jour nous recevons cédric
gras il est l'un des écrivains voyageurs
les plus brillants de sa génération dans
son dernier livre saison de voyage il
nous livre une réflexion sur le voyage
du 21e siècle à l'ère du numérique et du
gps le dépaysement est il encore
possible
notre invité un brin nostalgique à sa
réponse à cette question mais d'abord
cette affaire benalla du nom d'alexandre
benalla chargé de mission sécurité à
l'elysée
vidéo sont accablantes l'homme frappe
des manifestants du 1er mai avec un
brassard et un casque de police
et ce n'était pas la première fois qu'il
employait des méthodes musclées puisque
l'un de nos journalistes en a fait les
frais il ya un tout petit peu plus d'un
an
quentin calmer sur ces images qui
interpellent et qui choque depuis hier
soir un proche collaborateur d'emmanuel
macron chargé de mission à l'elysée n'a
pas passé par terre l'homme identifié
comme étant alexandre benalla s'en prend
violemment un manifestant le jour du 1er
mai une vidéo qui posent de multiples
questions pourquoi cet homme était-il
équipé d'un casque et d'un brassard de
police at il été autorisé à se rendre à
cette manifestation
fred est quand même très étonnant que
quelqu'un travaillant à l'elysée à ses
proches du président de république se
soit retrouvé dans cette situation la
question qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il
faisait sur le terrain en quelle qualité
ce qui était face au tollé provoqué par
cette vidéo c'est le porte-parole de la
présidence qui a fait une déclaration ce
matin à l'elysée il a été mis à pied
pendant quinze jours avec suspension de
salaire il a été démis de ses fonctions
en matière d'organisation de la sécurité
des déplacements du président une
déclaration bien insuffisante pour les
parlementaires
depuis la révélation de l'identité de
cet homme par le journal le monde
certains demandent des comptes à
l'exécutif
la moindre des choses ce serait que le
sénat le parlement et le sénat en
particulier puis auditionné le ministre
de l'intérieur et la ministre de la
justice puisqu'on nous a visiblement
cacher des choses graves
ce matin le parquet de paris a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour chef de
violence par personne chargée d'une
mission de service public
également pour usurpation d'identité et
usurpation de signes réservé à
l'autorité publique
je pense que la première des choses
c'est
que la justice établisse les faits
deuxièmement je pense quand même que le
parlement doit dire haut et fort au
président de la république que la
république exemplaire qu'ils prônent est
totalement contradictoire avec cette
affaire alexandre benalla un personnage
qui s'était signalé il ya plus d'un an
le 4 mars 2017
lors d'un meeting du candidat en marche
à quand il s'était permis de ceinturer
et d'évacuer un journaliste de la
rédaction de public sénat
après avoir arraché son accréditation
presse des faits qui auraient dû déjà
alerter l'entourage des manuels macron
avec nous pour aller plus loin ce soir
des habitués de bpl qu'on est ravi
d'accueillir pour la dernière de la
saison alexia germond bonsoir fondatrice
et présidente du think tank france
audacieuse bruno cautrès bonsoir on
solito log et chercheur au cevipof
emmanuel rivière bonsoir en politologue
directeur général de l'institut kantar
public ait eu de réponse fois rédacteur
en chef du parisien week end avant
d'aborder vos thèmes respectifs on va
effectivement réagir à cette affaire
benalla qui s'emballe un syndicat de
police portent plainte pour usurpation
de fonction gérard collomb a annoncé
qu'il avait saisi l'igpn edouard
philippe s'est également exprimé sur la
faire tout à l'heure au sénat la faire
aller désormais
aux mains de la justice et c'est très
bien ainsi
elle est désarmée elle est désormais aux
mains de la justice
et c'est très bien ainsi
un certain nombre un certain nombre de
questions ne manqueront pas d'être posée
je souhaite nous souhaitons tous que
cette enquête permette de déterminer les
faits précis les raisons claires
l'enchaînement des décisions qui ont été
prises sur ce sujet je vous remercie
alex égèrement sale affaire du jour
peut-être même de l'année est ce qu'on
va faire dans ce scandale d'état comment
vous voyez cette affaire en tout cas ce
n'est ni une simple erreur politique ni
même une maladresse politique je crois
qu'on peut parler d'une quasi bavure
politique
on s'est très il ya plein de questions
autour de ce sujet là qu'est ce qu'il
faisait sur place la façon dont ça a été
traitée l'adéquation des sanctions qui
ont été prises
même si c'était une mise à pied avec non
paiement du salaire pendant quinze jours
il reste que cette personne même si
c'était précisé d'ailleurs dernier
avertissement avant licenciement il
reste que cette personne reste dans
l'entourage du chef de l'état au sein de
au sein de l'elysée
après on ne peut pas reprocher à
emmanuel macron d'être heureux en tout
cas on ne peut pas le rendre comptable
de l'ensemble des comportements des gens
autour de lui en revanche on peut le
rendre comptable de la façon dont ils
traitent le sujet une fois que ça lui
est remonté on
voilà donc pour moi c'est une affaire
très sérieuse effectivement 4 est une
affaire très sérieuse
oui oui c'est clairement une affaire
extrêmement sérieuse le premier ministre
d'ailleurs au fond dit dit tout dans la
déclaration qui vient de faire deux au
sénat et dit désormais c'est aux mains
de la justice et il appuie sur le
désormais bien c'est justement c'est un
peu le problème c'est désormais
effectivement et ce qui va remonter
progressivement c'est comment se fait-il
que ça ne soit connue qu'aujourd'hui
alors que les faits datent du 1er mai
qu'elle a été l'enchaînement
effectivement de décisions qui ont
conduit une personne à avoir un brassard
de la police nationale autour du bras ce
qui n'est quand même pas rien on se
doute que ce brassard et de l'apa
acheter au supermarché du coin donc
quelqu'un lui a donné donc ça pose
évidemment compte c'est toutes ces
questions et bien sûr il ya en toile de
fond cette fameuse obligation de toute
personne qui est détentrice de
l'autorité publique ou qui est un simple
fonctionnaire je suis fonctionnaire ça
s'applique tout à fait à l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires qui est normalement
l'obligation de porter à la connaissance
des autorités judiciaires tout
comportement criminel délictueux dont un
fonctionnaire dépositaire de l'autorité
publique a connaissance
emmanuel rivière c'est trop fort de
parler de potentiel scandale d'état
c'est pas une affaire gravissime c'est
pas il n'y a pas un scandale sanitaire
il n'ya pas des détournements de fonds
espèce de collusion avec une puissance
étrangère mais il ya une accumulation de
faits qui tous sont graves et qui touche
tous une dimension particulière qui
correspondait plutôt aux atouts des
manuels macron savoir à savoir rompre
avec des pratiques police et politique
pardon du passé vous avez compris de
lapsus km espèce de barbouzeries
l'entourage d'un chef d'état on pensait
que c'était du 20e siècle la notion de
respect de l'ordre républicain qui est
très souvent présent dans la bouche du
président la république on fait
facilement aujourd'hui la comparaison
avec la manière s'il avait repris un
jeune qui avait osé l'appeler manman'm
là ça fait un peu désordre puis à la
question de la maîtrise tout ça ne
semble pas maîtriser le sentiment
d'impunité au 6 à 7 13 c'est très
important pour les français une idée
qu'on puisse avoir commis une grave
erreur et hop un tour de passe passe on
y est il est plus là mais enfin il est
quand même dans le bus des joueurs de
l'équipe de france là où tout le monde
rêverait d'être donc il est encore là et
puis moi ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné
c'est que la communication ce matin
donner vraiment le sentiment que la
mesure n'était pas prise peut-être parce
qu'on a pensé comme je disais au départ
que c'était que c'était pas si grave que
ça le sauf que voilà c'est le sujet du
jour dans les médias c'est le sujet du
jour dans les quelques jours un jeu
probablement pour quelques jours il
devrait au moins quelques jours je pense
même que ça va quand même traîné un peu
cette affaire parce que beaucoup de
questions se posent
moi je suis aussi surpris
pour avoir souvent loué les qualités de
drh de emmanuel macron et même à ce
micro cette fois du recrutement de ce
personnage qui quand même n'est pas à
son coup d'essai puisque lorsqu'il était
chauffeur d'arnaud montebourg il a eu un
accident il a commis un délit de fuite
il a été viré par montebourg au bout
d'une semaine je le rappelle gestion de
téléspectateurs pendant la campagne il
s'en est pris 1 d'aujourd'hui pendant la
campagne
vous l'avez rappelé par votre sujet il
sonne appris de manière aussi violente
un jour avait à un journaliste sans
raison apparente
évidemment sans raison apparente j'ai
envie de dire et là encore on ne sait
pas très bien ce qu'il s'est passé
qui est ce manifestant est pourquoi il
s'en prend si violemment mais ce
personnage que je dors j'ignorais le nom
et l'existence alors comme beaucoup de
gens je pense mais qui avait quand même
une fonction dans l'organigramme
puisqu'ils même chef adjoint de cabinet
c'est par un titre très élevé et qu'il
n'apparaîtrait pas dans l'organigramme
officiel d'après le monde
n'empêche quand même qu'il a ce titre là
et que le chef de cabinet c'est quand
même celui qui en général se charge de
l'agenda du président est très proche du
président c'est beaucoup de choses même
de la vie personnelle du président qui
est souvent le chef de cabinet ce que
parfois d'affaires un peu privée du
président donc le chef adjoint d'abord
il me semble t'il pas toujours eu dans
les précédentes mandatures président et
est alors ce rôle lié en particulier à
la sécurité avec ce personnage qui a
fait tout son parcours au parti
socialiste qui a été proche même de
françois hollande qui était au ps et
c'est ce personnage paraît
particulièrement trouble et je suis très
surpris pour ma part qu emmanuel macron
qui est souvent très prudents quand ils
recrutent et qui avait d'ailleurs je
crois pris des précautions avec certains
ministres
certains malgré bon là je pense qu'une
imprudence total à mettre au coeur de la
maison au coeur de la machine
au coeur du réacteur en tel personnage
et on y reviendra évidemment dans un peu
sous le choc
dans notre match des idées sur le plan
de la communication justement la
communication présidentielle sur cette
affaire qui pose aussi des questions et
c'est une affaire qui intervient alors
que le chef de l'état n'est pas au mieux
dans les sondages pire les mots des
françaises sont très dures c'est le
thème que vous avez choisi bruno cautrès
vous avez constaté au cevipof que
l'étiquette de président des riches
étaient collés et bien coller oui moi ce
qui me frappe offert au fonds au cours d
eau cours des derniers mois on voit bien
qu emmanuel macron n'est pas dans la
même position que ses prédécesseurs
du point de vue des logiques et de la
temporalité de sa popularité et son
impopularité bien sûr ils rencontrent
cette fameuse malédiction de la
popularité qui caractérise tous les
présidents et tous les exécutifs maman
en europe en général il est en train de
rentrer dans cette logique où il ya des
mécontentements qui s'expriment mais ce
qui m'a beaucoup surpris depuis quelques
mois c'est que les français qui
s'opposent à emmanuel macron et bien il
emploie des mots une terminologie un
répertoire de vocabulaire ok de plus en
plus négatif de plus en plus dur il ya
une sorte d' asymétrie entre les options
positive et des opinions négatives les
opinions positives sont toujours forte
emmanuel macron a toujours l'image à la
fois de quelqu'un qui va au bout de son
programme qui a un vrai projet qui
défend ses idées avec beaucoup de
passion avec beaucoup de volonté les
français le crédite de son image aussi
international de président de la
république qui fait président ça c'est
incontestable par contre les maux qui
sont posées par ceux qui ont une opinion
négative sur emmanuel macron c'est
effectivement à la fois le côté
méprisant hautains et arrogants pas
l'écoutent et puis cette image de
président des riches qui je crois lui
maintenant assez fortement au collet et
dont je ne vois pas très bien comment il
va s'en il va sans s'en départir on voit
que cette image de président des riches
va de plus en plus elle est associée
aussi à l'image d'un président qui est
méprisant qui est hautain qui n'écoutent
pas au fond que ceux qui s'opposent ça
veut dire que peut-être les éléments de
langage de l'opposition ont fini par
faire mouche avec saint germain oui je
crois qu'il paye aussi la confrontation
avec la réalité tout simplement au bout
au bout d'un certain temps d'abord les
français sont bien loin aujourd'hui
d'avoir renoué avec la politique ce
n'est pas l'élection d' emmanuel macron
qu'il aura effacé cela est souvent on a
tendance à faire un saut un peu trop
rapide à mon oreille dans le la
présentation des choses
ensuite je crois que les français
attendent véritablement des résultats
concrets comme toujours comme à chaque
mandature sur trois grands sujets sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur la croissance et sur
l'emploi
or sur ces trois sujets pour l'instant
on a le front de l'emploi qui stagne la
croissance qui bien qu'ayant remontée se
tassera un petit peu et sur le pouvoir
d'achat on voit bien qu'il y a ça rue
dans les brancards a juste à juste titre
et en parallèle alors je rajouterais
quand même que sur le président des
riches
il ya également l'étiquette peut-être
deux présidents des villes aussi qui va
de pair mais qui est quand même assez
fortement en métropole des métropoles et
dernier point le boomerang ce que
j'appelle le boomerang du en même temps
c'est à dire la déception
la déception de l'ale droite de
l'électorat et la déception de l'ale
gauche sur la droite vous avez une
déception quand même sur les 4 à 6 m eur
non j'aurais mis sur la baisse sur la
non baisse des dépenses publiques
aujourd'hui on est quasiment nulle part
je pense que ça c'est un vrai sujet vrai
sujet a également qui est la politique
migratoire avec une loisil et
immigration qui n'a contenter personne
c'est en février ou mars si on se
souvient bien donc ça ce sont deux pôles
qui en plus donne aujourd'hui le
sentiment avec le retour de sujets
sociétaux sur lesquels
l'électorat de droite ne sait plus trop
comment se se préparer puis l'électorat
de gauche on voit bien effectivement sur
la partie sociétale et je rajouterais
peut-être sur la laïcité ou iliad et les
attendre au tournant et s'attarde c'est
même parfois j'ai des électeurs qui ont
voté pour lui
dès le premier tour un des secteurs qui
étaient de la famille de la gauche on va
dire qu'ils ont voté pour lui au premier
tour
c'est encore plus fort c'est des
électeurs qui l'ont rejoint au second
tour ça c'est très clair et on voit
qu'en parallèle de tout ça il ya aussi
les évolutions internes delà de la
gauche s'est versé beaucoup du côté de
la victoire de la france insoumise que
cette opposition est la plus nette et la
plus la plus dure du côté de l'éleveur
de centre gauche qui est socialiste on
va dire les choses quand même aussi sont
en train de bouger il est en train aussi
de décevoir cette partie des kings bien
c'est moins dur nous du côté lecteur de
la france est sous l'ios qui ne peut pas
inverser la tendance on attend son plan
pauvreté on apprend on attend une phase
plus sociale 1 de ce quinquennat on
attend un plan santé ce qui peut sortir
de cette étiquette président des riches
il donnerait il ya quatre ans on m'a vue
en ce sens que il est dans son propre
agenda
il est dans son calendrier il n'avait au
sortir de la présidentielle il n'a
quasiment plus tôt position ni de droite
ni vraiment de gauche
ou en tout cas d'une gauche qui n'est
pas une gauche de gouvernement donc pas
très crédible le front national est dans
un piètre état et donc je pense que dans
son timing est un peu confié dans son
entourage aussi c'est que ils se sont
dit c'est le moment de faire
au fond tout ce qui est impopulaire mais
qui va permettre de relancer le pays et
la catégorie qui est satisfait que l'on
apparaître tous les insatisfaits c'est
quand même plutôt le monde de
l'entreprise c'est le monde des start up
c'est le monde des gens qui vont faire
que la croissance va repartir et qui
peuvent éventuellement relancer l'emploi
qui est majeure cela sont plutôt
satisfaits se félicite quand même plutôt
de la présidence macron évidemment pour
que décoller cette étiquette de
président des riches de la far qui
abandonnait l'acte 2 du quinquennat et
je pense que comme c'est quelqu'un qui
est assez prévoyants calculateur et qui
est un peu le maître des horloges
il sait à quel moment
basculer et commencer à reconquérir cet
électorat de gauche qui se reportait jeu
aussi sur lui et qui l'a fait élire et
pour certains ils ont cru qu enfin avec
un qui allait faire la synthèse entre en
gros ce qu'ils admirent de la droite et
de mire de la gauche ont le temps presse
il faut qu'on continue de revenir sur
les faits marquants de l'année emmanuel
rivière vous avez eu envie de nous
parler de la recomposition du paysage
politique c'est pas ça un petit lien
quand même avec ce qu'on vient de dire
deux nouveaux patrons deux partis
historiques et un nouveau nom pour un
autre parti historique
tout cela il faut bien dire dans une
indifférence relative quand on part de
si loin
quand il ya tente à faire à refaire
quand il faut tout changer tout
reconstruire on a besoin de toutes les
énergies et de toutes les forces pour
réussir vous avez envoyé un message qui
est un message sans ambiguïté oui ce
soir nous pouvons dire la droite est de
retour
le nom rassemblement national que je
vous ai proposé ne correspond pas
seulement à la stratégie du mouvement
national qui est aujourd'hui de s'ouvrir
d'accueillir en son sein et à ses côtés
de nouveaux talents
mais il sonne aussi comme un cri de
ralliement
emmanuel rivière une année post
présidentielle avec énormément
changements dans le paysage politique et
finalement ça intéresse peu et on le
voit peu oui peut-être parce que ça me
fait plus sens pour les français surtout
ça qui est frappant et qui a marqué
cette année politique les deux
principaux partis qui marque l
alternance au cours des dernières
décennies ont changé de patron on peut
pas dire que ce soit totalement anodin
c'est à dire c'était pas juste un
remplacement technique la ligne de
laurent wauquiez
saleh a été très vite lue comme une
ligne plus droitière plutôt inspiré par
la droite populaire la ligne 2 d'olivier
fort apparaissait plus à gauche que la
ligne incarner précédemment par
notamment jean christophe cambadélis et
pourtant l'impression que ce sont des
non événements politiques alors ça ne
devrait pas ce ne devrait pas parce que
l'émergence d' en marche et l'élection
d' emmanuel macron a de toute évidence
bouleversé le paysage politique et donc
de proche en proche il devrait se
reconstruire des choses soit autour de
ces parties là show autour de nouveaux
partis sauf qu'il se reconstruit pas
grand chose il se reconstruit pas grand
chose en fait ce qu'on constate dans
l'eau dans nos enquêtes notamment notre
baromètre pour le figaro magazine qu'à
un peu 40 ans d'âge
c'est que ce qui est la tendance
émergente c'est le nombre de gens qui
disent ne plus se reconnaître dans aucun
parti politique et y compris est en
marche pâti de cela c'est 34% dans notre
dernier baromètre alors que c'était un
étiage qui oscillait entre 20 et 25 et
quelques les mauvaises années là il ya
une tendance croissante et donc ça c'est
derrière ce peine que l'on qu'on sache
les partis politiques y compris
d'ailleurs le rassemblement national où
là encore on devrait être sur quelque
chose qui soit un bouleversement majeur
le parti d'extrême droite qui tend la
main qui crée les conditions possibles
pour des alliances et là haut à nouveau
il ne se passe rien la france insoumise
qui s'en tire pas si mal que ça mais qui
quand même aussi un petit peu en perte
de visibilité et donc on est dans une
phase où la déconstruction continue il
faut que je trouve que c'est un fait
important majeur c'est que on a un peu
vite cru que l'élection d' emmanuel
macron solde est la crainte du populisme
la crainte de l'éclatement du paysage
politique
non il ya encore des facteurs très
agréable très aggravées et très
inquiétant du désintérêt voire de
l'hostilité à l'égard de la classe
politique et des modes d'action
politique traditionnelle d'accord avec
marc bouche non non je mettrai pas sur
le même plan le cas du rassemblement
national avec le cas de lise efforts et
de rang wauquiez autant l'opération
olivier forts et faibles par des mois le
mauvais jeu de mots mais c'est vrai que
ce garçon
qui censé être jeune plutôt fringante c
est ce qu on peut peu présent voilà il
est toujours triste au fait que les
problèmes de charisme problème de 10 des
problèmes de d'autorité problème de tous
laurent wauquiez il semble avoir
beaucoup de difficulté à rassembler sa
famille il ya une pression très forte au
sein des républicains mais vraiment
réforme pécresse bertrand les derniers
baron qui sont là et on sent bien qu'ils
en gros le veulent faire sa peau donc il
ya beaucoup de mal à jouer en revanche
je trouve que l'opération rassemblement
national comme premier étage de la fusée
pas si mal réussi
on retrouve que madame marine le pen au
sortir de la présidentielle de ce fameux
débat était très abîmé et finalement on
voit dans les sondages ce qu elle reste
assez solide
allez je vais faire deux fois plus bas
que son étiage des années et quand même
encore dans une demain si on faisait un
premier tour de présidentielle je pense
qu'à nouveau le risquerait d'être au
second tour
je ne vois pas trop ça peut être une
constante
par ailleurs elle a ouvert quand même
elle a réussi à casser le nom du front
national après avoir écarté son père
après avoir écarté aussi quand même sa
nièce d'une manière ou d'une autre ou 7
débarrasser de la nièce moi je trouve
que l'opération quand même front
national et mutations et main tendue
avec aujourd'hui des gens dallaire qui
ont quand même répondu à ses appels etc
je trouve qu'on est encore loin de
l'échéance mais que petit à petit ça
prend forme et pour ma patrie mais ça va
pas besoin d'aller vite pour être solide
rapide parce qu'il ya deux autres
emmanuel rivière parle d'un
bouleversement du paysage politique je
pense qu'on pourrait même dire que le
paysage politique a été atomisée par
emmanuel macron et ça n'a pas encore
fini de se sédimenter il ya une
expression que je trouve assez parlant
de d'edouard philippe quand il dit la
poutre bouge toujours et il ne faut pas
oublier que on va avoir aussi cette
ligne de fracture très bientôt avec la
les élections européennes aussi faire
bouger le
nizar et on parlera de l'europe dans un
instant avec vous d'ailleurs rapidement
de trois observations la première on
observe qu effectivement dans l' enquête
que nous réalisons cevipof annuellement
sur la confiance politique l'anc est que
nous avons publié au mois de janvier
ne montrez pas de redressement fort de
la confiance des français dans la
politique on avait quelques indicateurs
qui allait un peu mieux mais globalement
le portrait que dresse cette enquête de
français qui sont toujours dans le
sentiment que la politique ou les hommes
politiques sont peu empathique des
problèmes des français qui sont tournés
vers eux mêmes vers leurs réélections
clos ans dans un monde qui n'est que le
leur et aidera domine toujours en
deuxième observation il ya des
compositions l'est forcément
recomposition en même temps et en toile
de fond de tous les mouvements qu'on
observe sur les partis politiques
toujours il ya quand même des lignes
très durs qu'on appelle nous les
clivages politiques et les deux grands
clivages politiques organisent notre vie
publique depuis plusieurs décennies en
fait la question gauche droite et la
question du rapport à la mondialisation
à l'europe continue continue d'être les
grands lignes directrices le clivage de
fameux clivage perdant gagnants de la
mondialisation ne date pas l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 y date du début
des années 90 votre thème yves derai
coupe du monde et politique là le
parisien week end ailleurs on fait sa
une cette semaine sur l'épisode du
mondial le grand roman des bleus c'est
le titre vous êtes notamment demander si
cette victoire des bleus pouvaient
profiter à emmanuel macron avant d'en
parler on va écouter le président le
soir où il a reçu l'équipe de france à
l'elysée
jean-yves à 7 mai qui met les mails
personnels unis
pour vous ils devraient ça va lui faire
gagner des points
on se souvient de en tout cas de jacques
chirac - 98 pour qui la victoire des
bleus avait été synonyme de rebond
puisqu'il avait gagné autour de 15 %
dans les sondages
là je pense pas qu'il en est de même
avec mylène macron je ne crois pas de
chiffre d'affaires d'un jardin tel
rebond encore moins que la sphère
d'aujourd'hui mais je pense néanmoins
que s'il a autant accompagner le
parcours des bleus est depuis avant le
début de la coupe du monde puisqu'il
était allé à clairefontaine etc c'est
qu'au fond ils les voient dans cette
équipe un petit peu le miroir de sa
propre action et de son propre parcours
et accepte équipe symbolise le saut
générationnel
on a balayé un petit peu les anciens qui
disons je me mettais un mauvais climat
dans le paysage il ya une nouvelle
génération qui s'est levé qui a gagné et
qui a gagné en jouant pas très bien en
tout cas en ayant un jeu pas très faim
papa très sympathique à regarder mais
qui néanmoins gagne et c'est un peu en
gros ce qu'on pourrait reprocher parfois
sa politique aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que elle est un peu dure à supporter
pour beaucoup de français
mais au fond comme les bleus il pense
qu'il va gagner et donc je pense que
dans cette parabole un petit bloc
holistique
il a aussi voulu valoriser d'une
certaine manière son propre bilan
alexia germe en votre faits marquants de
l'actualité concerne l'europe 2018 a été
l'année des crises et 2019 vous l'avez
dit sera une année charnière pourtant le
sujet n'intéresse pas vraiment les
français nous avons justement fait un
petit micro-trottoir tout à l'heure dans
paris pour savoir si les gens étaient ne
serait ce qu'au courant de ce scrutin
des européennes en 2019
vous êtes au courant qu'ils aient les
élections européennes dans un an
oui mais les bus non pas du tout simon
pas
seulement pas non je m'intéresse pas
seulement la politique donc c'est vrai
que je t'aime pas j'étais même pas au
courant
l'europe est une question d'actualité
très importante pour la france les
droits sont déjà voté au bon t'es déjà
fait quoi mais bon pas plus que ça je
suis pas vraiment intéressé pauvreté
parce que ça veut pas dire que tout va
changer du tout au tout mais sinon alors
après il faut se taire si on n'a rien
fait foster quoi voilà au micro de marie
brémaud et de femmes hier et cars et de
surprises alexeï guerman d'entente ça du
tout et tout est dit tout est dit parce
qu'en fait on est dans une europe qui
est complètement déconnecté avec les
citoyens européens
l'europe se meurt alors qu'on va rentrer
justement dans une année qui va être
terriblement européenne avec à la fois
le break site en mars 2019 les élections
européennes en mai 2019 et également
cette guerre commerciale qui commence à
prendre beaucoup beaucoup d'ampleur
entre la chine les etats-unis et
l'europe et à chaque passage dans un
match des idées sur les trois sujets
qu'on a on a toujours un des sujets où
il y a une patte européenne bien entendu
alors c'est un sujet d'autant plus
intéressant je trouve que dans un
contexte où il y à une montée des
populismes bien sûr et la prééminence de
la question migratoire est bien les
défenseurs de l'idée européenne doivent
monter au créneau donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui me paraît d'autant
plus intéressant quand on le fait de
manière non inféodé à un parti politique
c'est là où la voix de la société civile
experte donc libre peut être
intéressante en tout cas c'est la ligne
que que j'ai choisie en écrivant donc
ce livre réveillon notre europe qui sort
là en octobre en octobre prochain
emmanuel rivière il ya un vrai un
profond désintérêt des français pour
cette europe est et pourtant les
chiffres d euros baromètre notamment et
on s'est cru il ya à peu près un tiers
des gens qui savent quand sera
l'élection européenne
il ya la moitié des gens qui savent
qu'on y lit les députés européens du frh
d'universel ce qui montre bien
effectivement le désinvestissement de
cette élection mais n'a pas eu beaucoup
de pédagogie non plus pas vraiment de
campagne commune et ses bienfaits tant
qu'on continuera à traiter les uns les
élections européennes sous l'angle
exclusif du rapport de force entre des
partis politiques qui n'intéresse plus
grand monde au niveau national est ce qu
on se couchera sans savoir de quoi est
composé le conte parlement européen est
ce que ça veut dire pour l'avenir ça
risque de continuer à être le cas mais
la question européenne en revanche c'est
pas pour rien qu'elle s'est finalement
invité un peu par surprise dans les
principaux débats télévisés notamment
qui ont marqué l'élection présidentielle
parce que la plupart des sujets qui
préoccupent les français
les sujets de l'emploi mais il n'y ait
aucun thématique de la délocalisation
les sujets sociaux qui sont liées à la
pérennité de notre modèle social et
sujet de migration les sujets
d'environnement
ils sont pour eux des sujets qui
constituent notre rapport à l'extérieur
ils sont les sujets supranationaux il se
trouve que l'europe c'est notre
interface avec l'extérieur
mais la lisibilité de du rapport entre
un bulletin qu'on met dans l'urne est
quelque chose qui va se passer dont on
peut se dire ah j'ai eu cet effet là en
votant ça ça par contre ça manque
d'ombré d'un contrat sinon on va voir
cette visibilité il est urgentissime de
ne pas réduire le débat sur l'europe
à la question pro ou contre l'europe il
n'y a pas d'un côté les europhiles et
l'autre côté les eurosceptiques
l'opinion française dominante c'est
qu'on est à la fois français et
européens c'est l'opinion dominante
donc il est urgentissime de politiser le
débat sur l'europe et donc d'introduire
des éléments de conflictuelle it et sur
la question de l'europe et donc c'est
davantage le débat de demain qui et quel
type d'europe pour quoi faire au profit
de qui avec quelles orientations de
politique publique qu'est le grand débat
plutôt que de servir encore une fois le
débat sur aimer l'europe ou être un
obscurantiste
donc ce débat est dépassé c'est vraiment
la leçon que nous devons retirer depuis
il reste quelques secondes je crains
juste que le désintérêt que les gens me
semble manifester pour cette élection
face quand on se réveille sacrée gueule
de bois au lendemain de l'élection parce
que ceux qui seront mobilisés comme
souvent lors de ces élections la cedh et
les populistes et donc en risque d'avoir
scoré au dur assemblée nationale et de
la france en soumises et les pro
européens risquent d'être de ressortir
très affaibli de cette élection et nous
parlerons beaucoup d'europe la saison
prochaine dans au vpn sur public sénat
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce grand débat dans un
instant c'est le match des idées on va
revenir sur la stratégie globale de la
communication des manuels macron depuis
un an de la parole rare à l'omniprésence
médiatique sauf peut-être aujourd'hui
avec cette affaire benalla plus
qu'embarrassante qui s'abat sur l'elysée
fabien becker emmanuel macron voulait
garder de la hauteur ne s'exprimant pas
en dehors des discours officiels et
encore moins en présence des
journalistes le président à cultiver la
parole rare plus d'interviews le 14
juillet par exemple mais des apparitions
soigneusement choisis et mise en scène
comme avec le journaliste laurent
delahousse à l'elysée sans s'est élevé
le symbole présidentielle la rareté a
cédé la place à une communication quasi
quotidiennes sur les réseaux sociaux
en juin le président exposé ses vues sur
les aides sociales avec un vocabulaire
qui surprend le soir de la fête de la
musique
il transforme l'elysée en dancefloor
électro et pose avec un dj célèbre pour
son militantisme lgbt
quelques jours après avoir recadré un
collégien au mont valérien
lomé il assiste à un concert dans une
boîte de nuit de lagos pour délivrer un
message sur l'afrique
une omniprésence sur les réseaux pas
exempte de faux pas qui finit par
brouiller la cohérence du message
présidentiel avec nous pour ce match des
idées arnaud benedetti bonsoir
professeur associé en histoire de la
communication à paris sorbonne et jacky
isabello bonsoir commune et cofondateur
de l'agencé corning de la parole rare à
l'omniprésence médiatique est
aujourd'hui silence radio sur la sphère
benalla est ce que la communication
présidentielle encore une logique arnaud
benedetti on y comprend plus grand-chose
et siagne l'improvisation
oui certainement une part
d'improvisation dans la séquence que
nous sommes actuellement en train de
traverser mais vous savez là la
communication des manuels macron depuis
le début elle a toujours beaucoup évolué
et là il a affiché un principe de rareté
dans sa parole au tout début qui n'a pas
fondamentalement respecter
rappelez-vous de guantanamo non pas du
tout finalement depuis l'automne depuis
l'automne 2017 il ne cesse de
communiquer et de sueur saturer l'espace
médiatique avec des formats très
différentes
m le recours aux réseaux aux réseaux
sociaux qui peuvent être des interviews
à la presse audiovisuelle enfin avec
différentes façons de s'exprimer et de
se mettre en scène
vis-à-vis du public mais là dans la
séquence que nous traversons ce qui est
le plus surprenant finalement et moi
c'est ce qui me surprend le plus c'est
que jusqu'à présent la team macron en
termes de communication sur ces séances
sur c'est sur ces moments de risque que
constituer un certain nombre de menaces
pour l'image d'emmanuel macron avait
toujours réagi très vite avec une forme
de transparence avec eux des éléments de
langage extrêmement bien rodée et là on
a un temps de retard à l'allumage qui
fait que le président de la république
comme le gouvernement sont en train de
courir après les événements et on sait
que en matière de communication de crise
que je dis là n'est pas du tout original
mais c'est une réalité très pragmatique
c'est un vrai problème parce que tout
simplement il ne maîtrise plus la
situation est vrai quand on forme les
gens à la communication de crise dans
les entreprises et les organisations
on leur explique qu'il faut être
proactif et non pas réactif et
jusque là emmanuel macron avait plutôt
brillé par sa réactivité et puis son
sens du timing de ce qu'on appelle de
manière un peu grossière la cinématique
de gestion de des événements et si ce
qui nous est rapportée est vrai c'est à
dire cet acte gravissime qui s'est
déroulé le 1er mai et on l'apprend
qu'aujourd'hui le président de la
république nous révèle le feuilleton
l'été parce que les médias vont
feuilletonner autour de chacune des
informations qui constituent ce dossier
et si on l'aimé diamant foyers dans les
uns après les autres il y en a des kilos
moi qui suis très proche de l'univers
militaire cet homme-là est un réserviste
de la gendarmerie et portait un casque
de crs de la police nationale ne serait
ce que ça vous allez voir comment les
institutions vont se réveiller la police
a non seulement en fonction est
exactement et au delà du fait qu' on en
parlait avec arnaud tout à l'heure le
moindre chef d'entreprise qui a des
chauffeurs qui se balade dans paris et
qui parfois agacés par les klaxons des
gens osent lever la main soit quelqu'un
s'est immédiatement licencié pour faute
lourde 1 dans la hiérarchie des fautes
et là on nous expliquerait que d'avoir
tabassé quelqu'un ce serait juste 15
jours de mise à pied essayez-vous
rebecca de mettre une gifle à quelqu'un
vous verrez comment vous allez être
traitée de tous les paramètres de cette
affaire sont assez gravissime et vos
invités précédents ont expliqué que
emmanuel manque macro ont commencé à
être ancrée quelque part un président
des riches mais on commence à le sceller
à un endroit et ça c'est pas très bons
avec cette affaire là c'est pas
président des riches
mais c'est un peu dictateur des riches
qu'on risque d'avoir si il ne gère pas
les symboles de l'hyper violence qui
sont derrière ces images et dont son
proche collaborateur est un symbole
absolument scandaleux mais on
s'interroge comment qu'est ce qu'il
aurait dû faire comme henri tu peux
faire est ce que prendre la parole ce
n'est pas aussi donner plus d'importance
à la faire et continuer d'aller
il aurait fallu réagir beaucoup plus
vite manifestement c'est vrai que entre
la révélation de la vidéo par le monde
hier soir vous riez en fin d'après-midi
et la prise de parole la première prise
de parole officielle assez inédite
d'ailleurs au demeurant du port parole
de l'elysée bruno roger petit il se
passe toute une soirée toute une nuit où
les réseaux sociaux vont bruisser et où
surtout les opposants politiques vont
commencer à s'exprimer
je crois qu'il faut aussi regarder la
façon dont la france a soumise à
communiquer dans cette séquence on voit
très bien que autant la communication
des manuels macron est en train de
tâtonner et de chercher ses marques pour
répondre à la pression médiatique
autant la communication de jean luc
mélenchon a été particulièrement bien
réglée depuis le début de cette affaire
on a eu un certain nombre de porte
parole de la france a soumises qui se
sont exprimés via les réseaux sociaux
via les médias dans la soirée d'hier
soir hein et puis jean luc mélenchon qui
a porté l'estocade
ce matin où cet après midi donc il y à
quelque part une vraie difficulté pour
emmanuel à cran et l'autre difficulté
pour emmanuel macron c'est qu'il faut
jamais oublier la façon dont il a été
élu
il a été élu sur la volonté de
transformer les méthodes et les vieilles
pratiques politiques et donc le fond de
marque de macron c'est à dire cette
france nouvelles ou ce nouveau monde
il est particulièrement entachée par cet
épisode qui rappelle quand même des
épisodes que nous avons connu dans la
république des années 50 des années 60
des années 70 des épisodes qui qui
peuvent évoquer parfois les polices
parallèles et là on est en effet je
pense qu'il ya un vrai problème
et puis regardez à becca on a une photo
du président de la république avec ce
personnage c'est tout ce qu'on redoute
votre question est très pertinente parce
que dans ces sujets là on travaille tout
le temps en disant ce qu'on appelle
l'état de la gestion de la laërt il faut
toujours se dire bon alors est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on déclenche et ont par trop
tôt ou est ce qu'on oublie et on démarre
trop tard et donc qu'est-ce qui a dû se
passer la france a soumis ce qui a
tourné cette vidéo a dû garder au chaud
parce qu'en terme de communication
ce ne sont pas les plus mauvais et ils
se sont dit la séquence
sncf et l'actualité la coupe du monde
n'est pas propice à ça et maintenant
tout s'est aplani et donc le timing est
idéal pour contraindre le président de
la république à prendre la parole sur ça
sauf que s'ils n'ont pas eux-mêmes
trancher cette affaire
eh bien les français pour se dire mais
ils ont cinq 5 mois
ils ont trois mois de retard donc tous
les paramètres de cette affaire vont en
faire le feuilleton l'été surtout qu'il
y en a d'autres des vidéos nous avons
ressenti ce genre de public sénat
puisque l'un de nos journalistes a été
aussi chahuté et regardez ces images
c'était en mars 2017
lors d'un meeting des manuels macro à
coup c'était pendant la campagne
présidentielle on avait reproché à notre
journaliste de cette trop approché du
candidat macron lors d'un tournage pour
l'émission déshabillons-les revoyez le
résultat cet homme ce fameux alexandre
benalla qui a ceinturé notre journaliste
et la sortie manu militari c'était des
gens signal d' alerte il y aurait déjà
dû avoir quelque chose mais c'est
d'autant plus un signal d'alerté sécu en
plus ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que les policiers quand ils agissent de
la sorte sont très durement sanctionnés
par leur hiérarchie
donc si vous voulez il ya aussi cet
aspect là c'est à dire d'une république
à deux vitesses entre d'un côté des
pratiques qui sont totalement pathologie
parce que c'est quand même la première
fois que je vois pour ce qui me concerne
un monde de cabinets ministériels faire
la police n'y a pas d'autre expression
et des policiers qui eux quand même sont
soumis malgré tout un certain nombre de
règles qu'ils doivent respecter je
rappelle que dans la fonction publique
la police et les fonctionnaires de
police sont certainement ceux qui sont
parmi les plus sanctionnées 80% vers d d
d d d d d d des sanctions dans la
fonction publique touche
en règle générale donc il ya aussi ce
malaise qui est en train de s'installer
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la police
messieurs je vous avais demandé de
choisir des thèmes que vous avez jugé
marcon cette année puisque c'est la
dernière de la saison dispositif un
petit peu exceptionnel jacky isabello
c'était là comme présidentielle
justement on vient de le voir arnaud
benedetti vous avez choisi de revenir
sur la figure du héros car présenté
arnaud beltrame cette année officier de
gendarmerie tués lors de l'attentât de
trèbes et il avait pris la place d'une
femme prise en otage dans le super u
pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème mais
parce que on vit dans une société de
l'immédiat ou finalement les événements
sont très rapidement cannibaliser et ça
fait quelques mois que ce drame
héroïque s'est déroulée je pense qu'il
est bon de temps à autre de rappeler ce
qui a été quand même un acte qui nous
interrogent parce que finalement qu'est
ce qu'a fait arnaud beltrame
il y là et il est allé jusqu'au bout de
sa mission
il s'est sacrifié pour pour une certaine
idée de l'altérité et c'est quelque
chose qui nous interroge au delà de la
dimension héroïque dans une société où
finalement on se pose la question de
savoir qu'est ce que c'est que le sens
de l'existence
qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'est ce que
c'est que le sens de sa mission dans une
société qui parfois peut paraître un peu
artificiel arnaud beltrame vient nous
rappeler des choses qui me paraissent
qui nous paraissent essentiels et c'est
ce qui vraisemblablement a sur le moment
suscité l'émotion collective de cet
événement a suscité il y à il ya
quelques mois
jacky isabello vous avez envie de nous
parler de la folle communication de
donald trump
ça aussi ça marque oui juste rajouter
quelque chose par rapport à ce qu'a dit
a souligné
la prise de position de sa maman la
prise de position de mme allan beltrame
qui nous a donné une leçon et qui nous a
montré que l'éducation des jeunes
puisque c'est son fils était très
importante et pour elle elle avait élevé
ce garçon est elle n'était pas surprise
et elle trouvait ça absolument normal
même si en tant que ça qu'elle avait
connu le pire des outrages
alors oui cette communication de 30 pb
c'est vrai qu' on est passé en quelques
années de quelqu'un qui peut vous
démontrer ses talents de catcheur à un
prochain héros des bouquins de gordon
thomas ce qu'est le grand spécialiste
des services de renseignement dans dans
le monde parce que vous avez vu que des
politologues extrêmement respectée
aujourd'hui sont en train d'expliquer
que peut-être donald trump auront été
recruté par les services secrets russes
et ce président là réplique ce genre de
choses ils sont tellement perdus qu'ils
en viennent à envisager des choses
alors quand on voit les noms parce que
vous avez vu que donald trump même si
nous on le supporte pas en europe
politiquement jusque-là l'ensemble de
ses positions n'ont fait que conforter
son électorat en qu'on aime ou pas son
électorat c'est celui qui l'a porté au
pouvoir
et toutes ces positions ont conforté cet
électorat la seule attitude qui n'a
absolument pas été suivi par son
électorat et les médias qui informent
son électorat c'est cette espèce
d'attitude vis-à-vis de donald trump et
les américains sont capables d'être
pudibonds sont capables d'être
outrancier sont capables d'être
protectionniste mais si jamais vous
touchez avec le patriotisme et que vous
donnez l'impression de pouvoir trahir
cette grande idée de la nation
américaine alors là pour le coup on ne
joue pas dans la même cours d'eau que
cette communication elle est incroyable
et en un an et demi de pouvoir il en est
là qui a encore deux ans et demi avec
une phase électorale demi teinte qui va
y arriver
même dans les romans les plus
abracadabrantesques on ne pourrait pas
envisager un tel scénario et je voulais
le préciser et c'est la fin de ce match
des idées merci le dernier de la saison
merci beaucoup à tous les deux nous
avons été fidèles tout au long de
l'année j'espère qu'on retrouvera
évidemment l'année prochaine la saison
prochaine sur public sénat dans vos
instances et l'entretien du jour selon
cédric gras il est considéré comme l'un
des écrivains voyageurs les plus
brillants de sa génération il publie ce
livre saison voyage avec pluie nous
allons essayer de voir ce que signifie
voyager au 21e siècle dans nos sociétés
modernes suréquipés le dépaysement est
il encore possible
là une petite idée ne dis ça juste après
cette courte pause la littérature quand
on a quand on vient d'un milieu ultra
modeste comme le mien on y est confronté
par l'école et comme j'ai pas fait de
longues études puisque j'ai arrêté
l'école en seconde j'ai une culture de
mazars sérieux on attrape tout et
n'importe quoi et puis positive qui
cessa film mais c'est vrai que
l'éducation sentimentale c'était quelque
chose qui m'a vraiment vraiment touché
au début puis un jour je suis tombé sur
camus à l'étranger de manière très
étrange
il est lu d'une traite assis au milieu
du bordel que pouvait avoir une famille
de tunisiens qui lisent en 35 mètres
carrés à la quatre voies avec dominique
farrugia et marc lambron demain à 22h
sur public sénat
l'info dans le rétro c'est un regard sur
l'actualité à travers l'histoire
en pratique si on regarde l'histoire
longue un certain nombre de réformes ont
été mises en échec par la rue qu'on peut
pas contester que la rue juin euros
chaque semaine
l'historien fabrice d'almeida décrypte
et analyse des faits d'actualité à
travers des images d'archivés de l'ina
un gouvernement ne peut que distribuer
les fruits de la croissance c'est
toujours le problème qui se pose encore
aujourd'hui une autre façon de
comprendre l'actualité
[Musique]
l'info dans le rétro demain à 23 heures
sur public sénat
[Musique]
de retour dans on va plus loin pour
l'entretien du jour et ce soir nous
recevons cédric gras bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes donc ce qu'on appelle un écrivain
voyageur vous êtes géographe de
formation et vous publiez saison de
voyage j'ai lu dans pas mal de papiers
que vous étiez plutôt un voyageur
mélancolique voire nostalgique le voyage
c'était mieux avant peut-être pourquoi
est-ce que vous allez nous expliquer je
préfère le terme de mélancolique mais
c'est d'abord ça correspond à mon
caractère et la nostalgie d'un monde que
je n'aurais pas connu ça ne m'intéresse
pas
c'est parce que la presse a besoin
évidemment de mer est belle si les
nostalgiques mais mon interrogation d'un
peu plus profonde et j'espère un petit
peu plus fourni c'est à dire que oui je
moi j'ai eu mon passeport
en 2000 j'ai eu 18 ans en 2000 et j'ai
voyagé non pas dans le xxème siècle mais
c'est dans le 21ème malgré tout le xxème
siècle a été absolument chamboulé et
donc on arrive sur un autre territoire
du voyage avec sa géopolitique avec son
tourisme qui pour avoir commencé à la
fin du xxème siècle n'en a pas pour
autant pour moi explosé au début du 21e
siècle sur considérable quand on se
lance nous à 18 ans avec mes amis du
haut du 21e siècle dans le voyage en
arrive avec des millions d'autres
eric guillon qui auraient bien tort de
s'en priver donc évidemment qu'on ne
peut pas se poser la question du voyage
aujourd'hui comme cela pose est ce qu'on
a lu ce qu'ils racontent leur épopée
dans les années 30 dressa 70-80 jusque
dans les années 90 parce que nous voyons
c'est un autre monde
qu'est-ce qui a été bouleversé ses
toutes dernières années expliquait nous
alors c'est cette question du gps du
fait qu'on ne va plus à la rencontre des
habitants parce qu'on a plus besoin
d'eux pour ce saurien hanter ce guide
est alors les nouvelles technologies ça
c'est sûr nous on voyage et encore avec
les vieux guide en papier en arriver à
des adresses qui était périmé il fallait
demander ça avait déménagé que c'était
aujourd'hui avec son charme il sacré est
ce qu'on peut à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler des micros péripéties qui font
partie ont vraiment du voyage ces
petites rencontres ces petits instants
qui aujourd'hui sont totalement gommée
effectivement par la facilité d'accès et
de réservation equilis totalement
effectivement le voyage alors même et
c'est un paradoxe convient en général je
cherchais un petit peu d' aventure même
si c'est ce contrôle l'açaï à
l'explosion du tourisme dont on vient de
parler il ya peut-être aussi énormément
de facilités de transport monsieur
facilités administratives l'ouverture de
tous ces pays qui a imposé des visas et
qui donc forcément rary fier aussi le
nombre de visites tous ensemble de
choses et puis sans doute la fin le
l'exploration et même de l'exploration
du détail il ya plus de terres vierges
dire il ya plus il ya plus de terres
vierges et non seulement elles ne sont
plus vierge mais en plus on en a une
connaissance parfaite et
qu'ils aient facilité non plus ce point
gps et la région du monde que vous
préférez celles eurasien c'est ça et en
particulier la russie où il avait vécu
oui la russie alors moi j'aime beaucoup
le parler de l'emploi beaucoup le terme
de ghazi parce qu'on parlait jusque-là
d'ex urss s'était lancé dans les années
90 aujourd'hui tous ces pays en ce temps
que personne ne veut pouvoir positionner
sur 24 et bien il se développe dans ils
sont souverains et que vous aimez
beaucoup je les aime beaucoup et ça fait
plus de vingt ans maintenant que le
reste et c'est tombé donc forcément il
se différencie de l'image qu'on avait de
la chute du mur donc l'eurasie me 121
beaucoup plus pertinent et je considère
que le ghazi c'est un petit peu le
territoire du voyage de ma génération
parce que justement il était fermé le
bloc politique ne permettait pas les
voyageurs de faire c'est toutes ces
régions c'était fermé alors qu'il y
avait cette route des hardes vers
katmandou qu'elle passait par la
yougoslavie la turquie l'iran
l'afghanistan qu'elle s'est un petit peu
fermé évidemment à cause des événements
géopolitiques de ces dernières décennies
et au contraire s'est ouverte cette
route d'asie centrale qui va jusqu'à
chine machine aussi s'est ouverte ce
n'était pas un pays dans lequel on
pouvait voyager vraiment facilement à la
fin du xxème siècle que ça je considère
que leur asie c'est un petit peu laperne
aventures de ma génération et vous aviez
été missionné un par le quai d'orsay
pour ouvrir l'alliance française à
vladivostok puis à donetsk puis à
kharkiv est abandonnée il a fallu
choisir entre eux être fonctionnaire et
être vraiment écrivain jacques lemaire
non j'étais contractuels c'est une
liberté vous avez choisi veeva choix
j'ai jamais petit voyage jamais tenté
aucun concours j'ai effectivement dans
un délai contractualisés
oui projet le ministère des affaires
étrangères surtout dans le réseau
culturel
aujourd'hui je me consacre ce qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire la littérature
avant d'ailleurs de voyager où je fais
aussi un petit peu de romans la
littérature pour moi est au dessus de
tout il se trouve que j'écris beaucoup
sur des contres et que je traverse mais
ça pourrait devenir un voyage immobile
d'esterra tuerait ce qui m'importe le
plus
et vous dit d'ailleurs que apprendre la
langue d'un pays fait partie du voyage
alors je crois que la langue oui ça fait
partie du voyage c'est aussi un des
moyens aujourd'hui où je me répète mais
le monde est quand même très très très
connus et visités
c'est un des moyens d'approfondir et
plutôt qu une frénésie spatiale qui
ferait enchaîné enfiler les pays comme
une perle
moi je conseille aux jeunes gens qui
veulent prendre la route parce que c'est
normal cependant après ses études
que ce soit une césure ou avant sur leur
entrée dans le monde professionnel
d'aller d'aller voir le monde c'est un
peu un rite initiatique
c'est un code un rite de passage qui
n'est nulle part mais qu'intuitive
lorsqu'on est jeune mais je leur
conseille effectivement pas forcément
d'aller faire un tour du monde qui
serait assez superficiel mais
d'approfondir par le biais mène alors
c'est une expatriation professionnels
immédiatement ça peut être s'engager
dans l'humanitaire
ça peut être dans l'écologie évidemment
mais l'approfondir dans un lieu alors
par le biais de la langue de s'intégrer
dans une société de mieux la comprendre
de l'intérieur d'approfondir des
relations des rencontres qui ne serait
pas celle de dix minutes autour d'un thé
sur le bord de la route
beaucoup de charline amant mais ça reste
très naïf et très superficielle part ça
je crois que s'installer pour mieux
comprendre un point de vue et voir le
monde d'un autre endroit de la carte ça
c'est une des choses qui et c'est ça le
vrai voyage de croo 28 mai ça comporte
des risques quand même vous l'avez
prouvé à vos dépends vous avez été
interpellé en chine pour espionnage
c'est ça il fait oui je suis au tibet
oui ça c'est encore autre chose c'était
une expédition d'alpinisme gels à la
jambe brisée en trois morceaux
r je ne suis plus combien on est sur un
seul mètre de 6000 m ça ça fait partie
effectivement des aventures que moi j'ai
eu envie d'y vivre c'est un peu plus
poussé je parlais tout à l'heure
cette idée des rites initiatiques c'est
vrai que quand on a 20 ans le voyage ça
peut être aussi le moment de voir ce
qu'on vaut entre guillemets peut-être
qu'on peut mais en garçon un garçon est
allé tester ses limites moi c'était
l'alpinisme et j'avais envie de faire
des choses qu'on fera pas évident
mokhtar vous tenez doux de vos parents
ce goût du voyage c'est parce qu'il vous
emmener crapahuter en europe le goût de
la montagne je le tiens de mes parents
jugement du voyage peut-être un peu
c'est vrai qu'on visite est beaucoup
l'europe mais on n'en étaient jamais
sorties d'europe avec mes parents les
trois frères par ailleurs qu'il voyage
de tant d'enfants comme tout le monde
qui n'ont pas pris la route autant que
moi donc je ne sais pas il ya quelques
ce dîner je pense dans cette espèce
d'appel du large
en tout cas tous les voyageurs que moi
je rencontre sur les routes du monde
ils n'ont pas forcément des raisons très
oui object traçable y avait des
illusions dans vos voyages mais c'est le
jeu mais justement c'est pour ça que
j'ai écrit ce livre c'est parce que on
doit pouvoir discuter du voyage et on
doit pouvoir parfois
revenir d'un voyage en faire une
narration qui est peut-être pas celle
qu'attend celui qui va vous écouter
parce que on a cette idée que le voyage
c'est forcément fantastique sur le futur
nom il ya beaucoup de choses très
décevante et ça fait partie du voyage
et c'est aussi pour cela que voyager ce
n'est pas forcément mieux que de rester
chez soi tout dépend de ce qu'on en fait
tout dépend d'eux aussi de parcours
n'est animé dans la vie il faut de tout
pour faire un monde et prendre la route
n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs une
obligation pour tout le monde il ya une
espèce de diktat parfois aujourd'hui il
faut voyager les gens de mettre sur un
cv etc
non c'est pas forcément fait pour toi et
puis c'est synonyme de grande solitude
aussi parfois le voyez il sait s'ils
donnaient battue
on peut aimer ça et j'aime ça et parfois
évidemment la solitude c'est comme tout
et rien que l'aider à rien d'idéal
parfois la solitude
ça vous donne à vous procure des moments
de grande euphorie
parce que c'est une la liberté je pense
ne peut être que conçue comme comme
comme une liberté où on est seul et en
revanche effectivement des choses proche
de l'art de la mélancolie dont on parle
espèce de grand vide parce que cette
solitude qui peut bien sûr avoir lieu
dans une grande ville enfin là où elle
est décuplée par la distance qui vous
sépare de toutes les choses qui d'un
coup vous apparaissent comme votre
environnement
votre votre patrie et là je ne parle pas
de donation et sentimentale voilà merci
beaucoup cédric gras de nous avoir parlé
de ce livret de vos voyages je rappelle
le titre de cet ouvrage saison de voyage
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur la dernière de la saison
je le rappelle celle de valence
exactement
et c'est pour ça que nous avons parlé
voilà j'espère que vous avez donné envie
à nos téléspectateurs de peut-être
voyager même si c'est seulement dans
leur tête et pas forcément en faisant un
déplacement merci encore c'est donc la
fin de cette émission je vous retrouve
avec un immense plaisir à la rentrée de
septembre pour de nouveau numéro d'on va
plus loin et peut-être quelques
nouveautés sur public sénat l'invité de
territoire d'infos demain c'est nicolas
bay député européen secrétaire général
du rassemblement national ex fn je vous
souhaite un très bel été une très belle
soirée est restée au coeur du débat
[Musique]
e